πουσιαστικά όπως απόγετ θα νακοινώσει και την κάθετοστες βουλεύτηκς είναι αυτή τρεις είναι πολύ περισσότερα
τα ονόματα που θα δούμε αφό απογιεται ότι θα έρθει πίσω και οχριστω στη λεανίδης
απογόνται αρκετά ονόματα από τον συναγερμό πως τον βλέπι τώρα να πούμε ότι ενμας αρέσει
εμάς που είμαστε στο χρο τις πολιτικής τις δημοσιογραφίας να συζητούμε για το κοσιοκτώ αλλά
έτσι για να βάλουμε τα πράγματα σες στο τές τος διαστάσεις έχουμε των οκτόύριον εκλογές
τα κατεχομε έχουμε το μάιον εκλο του χρόνου εκλογίες βλες εφτιές την κύπροτοκοσίευτά κάποια στιγμή
είναι έχουμείναι εκλογές την ελλάδαν και μέσα σε αυτή την περίοδώ θα έχουμε και εκλογίές
στην τουρκία άρα πριν φτάσουμε στο δικό πασκοσιοκτώ προηγούνται τουλάχι στον τρεις άλλες εκλογικές ανατα
επιστεύεισε ότι το συζητούμ ανδόχι ότι δεν είναι θεματον κάθημέρι να όχιδεδεν το λέω για
να πω ότι καταλήξει ότι ενάδεικα που το συζητούμε που μάλλον ενάδικα από τα συζητούμεα
διαπλώς κι εμίζουμε το χρόνον μας γιότι θα συμβον τόσα απο λλα πράγματα τα οποία
σήμερα αυτά που δεν ξέρουμε νι είναι πολύ περισσότερα απόσα αυτά που ξέρουμε για το
κοσιοκτώ του τον εντο ένα το δεύτερο είναι οι κινή λογική λέει ότι δεξιά μάλλον
θα έχει και πάλι δύο υποψηφίους τώρα θα είναι ανίτα χριστο δουλίδης δεν ξέρω στη
λιανήδης είναι δεξιά εριστερά θα το δούμε που θα τοποθετηθεί δι ότι ξεκίνησε από κάπου
ευρέθηκε εγκά που αλού μετάειτα στην ευρωπαϊκιμένωσυνιστρα στην ελλάδα δεν είναι πολύ υδιάκριτώ είναι και
ο κύριος θαμερόθνεοίτο είναι αβέροφωνι οφί τους στος δημοκρατικό συνογερμό είναι ο φέδονα σφέδονος δίολοί
α σχολούμαστε με τους γ και τους δοκατύρι στο φέδονα που κμνουν ο φεύορας φέδορος
χτίζει έναν πολύ συγκεκριμένων προφίλ το οποίον φαίνεται να εέίχει απίχηση ο φεδος